mais on n'a pas du tout rêver de cette
réforme telle qu'elle raye dessine en
tous les cas ça n'est pas mon cas ouais
bon moi ce qui compte c'est de faire en
sorte de garantir l'équilibré du système
de retraites dans la durée mais je ne
crois pas à cette réforme technocratique
telle qu'elle nous est présenté derrière
le rêve de construire un système
universel à points où chaque point
serait produit par la même valeur de
rémunération en réalité on va produire
des inégalités considérables des
injustices considérable on va créer une
immense tension et en même temps on va
réussir à faire une réforme qui coûte de
l'argent aux finances publiques